the blue jays wrapping up the two-game
series against the marlins in miami
trying to sweep it and trying for their
first four-game winning streak
of the season for the marlins 15th start
in 2021
for trevor rodgers 15 starts two earned
runs or less
in 13 of his 14 thus far beau hitting
276
14 home runs on the season
the shed lines one that's a fair ball
down towards the right field corner cut
off by duvall
and he does a nice job to hold bechet to
a long one-out single
tay oscar hitting an even 300 on the
season
joe won and hernandez hits it off the
end of the bat and that ball is down in
right field
the shed around third he'll come in to
score guerrero into third hernandez safe
at second
vladi dives back into third after
drawing a throw
and an rbi double for hernandez has
given the blue jays an early one to
nothing lead
just like that the blue jays have a very
quick lead
showing some speed and showing some
flexibility on that slide into second
base one to nothing blue chase
two in scoring position with one down
for george springer
and he hits one off the end of the bat
aguilar smothers it and feeds rogers at
the bag for the out
but a run will come in to score on the
play guerrero crosses
one two and a ground ball to the right
side aguilar has to feed rogers again
and safe at first well the umpires uh
are gonna get together and watch this i
mean rogers has the ball so we're just
looking at the feet i mean that's uh
that's a half step this should not take
that long at all
and it has been overturned but the jays
get a couple of runs in the first
against rogers for the second time this
year the marlins will get a look
at left-hander robbie ray this is for
the eighth time in his career he will
face the marlins he picked up the win
back on june the first gets the ground
ball to first vlad gets to it jazz
hustling down the line and he is safe
jazz cranking up the speed
he did not beat him to the bag but he
may have been able to
play it place a tag on jazz up high
before he gets to the back
there you go and he's out you're right
this is rolling up the line and it is
going to be a
fair bowl we saw this last night
2-0 and a fly ball lift to right center
field
but it will be playable just shy of the
track for randall bridchick and that
martay base hit will be stranded
and now a swinging a base hit into right
field for biggio and at least for a
moment duval
thought about maybe throwing to first
and trying to get the out there but
abhisheo
safely across with a base hit two and
two
and that time he goes to the changeup
and gets his first strikeout
and he grounds one down to third tricky
hop for birdie
picks it back up throws to first and
just in time
to get simeon and retire the blue jays
simeon's not entirely sure he was out
will they challenge again
absolutely they're calling them safe
they're not even going to look at it
with
into left field long run over for
sanchez and he makes the play
hit it on looking sharp in the early
going tonight
here is the o2 and it's there a fastball
for a strike three
called two down
ground ball to short to his left
pachette has it spins
fires and gets him good play by bo
buchet
and he hits a little chopper this could
be tricky and it's off the glove of
bisho
and rogers is going to reach
it should be a play that's made no cabin
is back
so he's got a long way to come i would
think that he would play it about
halfway
left-handed batter versus the
left-handed pitcher
nubs it out in front of home plate he
just can't come up with it cleanly
swinging a miss and a ball up and in two
down
two two and that is there strike three
call
martay down on strikes that's all for
the marlins
there's a called strike three rogers has
his second strikeout tonight
he's creeping up on 100 strikeouts on
the season
ball on two strikes and then he goes
right back to the high fastball
but if he can get to five strikeouts
tonight fifth marlins pitcher to strike
out a hundred batters in his first 15
games joining jose fernandez caleb smith
annabelle sanchez aj burnett
and he'd be the first rookie to do it
well a swing and a miss
ball was in the dirt up with it the
catcher and adams throws down to first
complete the strikeout
the fifth in the game for ray
sliders sent to left field hernandez
back and he makes the catch
deep in left field nice play by t oscar
simeon grounded out and then reached on
an air so officially over two
simeon lifts a fly ball left center
field well hit and it's going to be off
the base of the fence
it bounces past martay sanchez picks it
up
gets it back into the infield but simeon
is aboard with a leadoff double
now buchet and he swings and lines it
into left field a base hit
simeon around third getting the wave the
throw to the play
not in time it's an rbi single for
beshet
and it is three to nothing blue jays
you're trying to play for a big
inning marcus siemens at second base
beau slashes that ball
into left field aggressive
coaching from louis rivera as they send
the runner from second base but a good
piece of hitting also from beau buchet
he said i'm not going to try and hit the
ball the other way
i'm going to try and drive him in
wherever they pitch it
cut on and missed beat him with a slider
3 33 last nine games but
here rogers gets another strikeout
100 strikeouts now for trevor rogers
first rookie to do that in his first 15
games of a season
but rogers gets the strikeout martay
tonight an infield hit and he's also
been called out on strikes
martine line drive left center field
carries out of here for a home run
starling marte gets the marlins on the
board in the sixth inning with a solo
shot
i'll leave it to marty to jump start
this off it's just a little bit it
certainly feels like the blue jays are
way out in front the way this series has
gone but it is a three to one ball game
here in the sixth in a
big swing from marta
swinging to miss gets him on the sinker
for out number one here in the seventh
bass comes home with a 1-2 and he gets
him swinging
back-to-back strikeouts for bass here in
the seventh
and anthony bass has himself three
strikeouts in the seventh inning
he's only had one outing where he's
giving up a run
there's a bouncer to third scooped up by
biggio
and out at first on a big stretch by
guerrero
that is a tough stretch coming into the
base runner
ground ball right side aguilar gets one
over to
first and safe it's the left foot that
you have to keep your eye on right
the last one's gonna hit right here oh
yeah no he didn't get there
and then jazz touches it so that that's
that's a double play
that has to be a double play there he's
out okay there you have it a three
six four double play adam duvall to lead
it off
and there's the base runner they need
down the line and toward the corner
duvall on his way to second
he will get there with a lead off two
base hit
the e01 fastball and a weak ground ball
to second
simeon's got it flipped to first for out
number two
duvall to third with the blue chase now
and out away
and the one two on the way swan lawn and
missed he got him
and the blue jays beat the marlins again
sweep the season series from the marlins
go to 13-2 in inner league play
and now have their first four-game
winning streak tabby of the season